hello and welcome to this video playing
i am manikri
manikri we'll see what he's going for
i'm hoping for
you know what i'm hoping for
he's thinking about it in the way he
probably is not thinking about
okay you don't see this so often
i actually analyzed that in fight like
magnus
[Music]
it's um actually interesting it's not um
this is not um bad for white at all
the the capture on e4 is a slightly
risky choice
but i never expected to ever get that on
the board but because bishop c4 is
basically never played by a stronger
player
and he's an i am so
um
there should be seven
i have gotten the bishop pair that's
nice but
on the downside
white has used a huge development
advantage
and this is probably
balanced it's this is it this is at
least what i remember that is balanced
maybe that was even a bit riskier for
for black
i don't quite remember i know that i
analyzed this
it's a good amount of time
yeah the rook is certainly
somewhat exposed here so that makes them
makes it a bit difficult to develop in a
normal way
yeah here for example f5 yeah is a move
that
yeah wins material
i think
it also can be pretty dangerous
yeah come on if he has a brilliant
refutation of this move or maybe maybe
i'm just
totally stupid and knight takes e6
maybe yeah because he has knight c7
no went to b5
knight c7 check hmm
what kind of a game is that you want to
take with the c3 knight or what or is
that just an
im using a comp sorry
i this is a very strange game
also this this kindergarten line with
bishop c4
it's really weird
really weird
it makes absolutely no sense if that is
an
i am and he's using a computer i mean
and
it's very strange
okay knight takes knight c7 doesn't work
check with this
it's not even in the least
bit getting faster
not at all
king e7 is there's a knight xf5
if i go to g6 in this position
it's got h5 maybe
what a weird game i mean
it's just so odd
you have this opening that is never
played by a strong player because black
has
such an easy game i can go d5 for equal
play and so on it's
fairly clear yeah and then
place extremely slow
and also this this weird queen takes d1
takes
ages to reply
i find also this whole concept odd but i
don't know okay
maybe after a while you're getting
paranoid
so it seems to also not work this is it
this is the weirdest thing so take
take i can actually take the rook
i didn't consider that at all i thought
that he would just
be good here but i have e5
so clearly that was not a computer my
main my main problem was
that he took
13 seconds to recapture with the rook
which is really strange
but i don't know
yeah you simply have to ignore things
like that i mean people do whatever
um and here we made a draw
i mean i wanted to continue because of
the time but i simply
cannot i have no way to continue i think
okay the computer says i can go to h7
here but that looks really risky
yeah i was i was completely spooked by
now after i mean
the whole opening is weird also bishop
f4 is a
bit of an odd move and then then he took
13 seconds for that which made me
totally paranoid
and it doesn't work it was just like i
can i can take the rook
if we look at this like here i will um
i'm i'm i'm double attacking i'm just
winning stuff
yeah i'm sorry i shouldn't be so
paranoid but
it's just weird sometimes what happens
yeah so i had a chance there but i
didn't take it at the end
i didn't see how to sensibly avoid it
raw thanks for watching